hey
what's up guys we did it we're back on
another saturday morning
we're going to learn and grow together
we're talking about
how to create sci-fi interiors with
cinema 4d but hey if you're using
blender or 3ds max or maya
whatever you know we can all learn
something
today in the next couple hours together
that's the whole point of these things i
do them every single week for you guys
and uh we just create some cool stuff
and we learn a lot of cool stuff
together
because there's always there's always
stuff to learn
as soon as you as soon as you realize
like hey i've learned everything there
is to learn
i apologize because we got a lot
to talk about um we're going to be
making or recreating this
awesome photo by photographer joe
nishizawa he's one of my favorite
photographers of all time
if you google this guy he has some of
the most
incredible uh like industrial
um photography let's see nishis
uh what and you might have seen some of
his photography around
um specifically this one
right here of like these these giant
sewer tunnels in japan
but man he just has like the coolest
stuff that's joe
nishizawa so we're going to be
recreating one of his
photographs here i'm using octane
if you guys um for those of you who are
who are curious
a lot of you have probably joined me
before on these adventures but uh we're
gonna try and recreate this photo from
start to finish on the stream all right
so grab your coffee or your kombucha
or your um mountain dew whatever
you guys are drinking um and let's dive
in so if you guys aren't subscribed
already to my channel
definitely subscribe because you know i
do this all the time if you like
what you're seeing then then let's get
notified you know let's get notified of
when i'm coming back
every single saturday i do not miss a
saturday
unless for whatever reason i'm sick or
whatever i think i've missed two
over the last six or seven months
but uh thanks for joining a um we have
our boy
dinkle winkle here in the chat he is
moderating so
don't spam all right don't be a butt
because
mr dinkerwinkle will find you he will
track you down
and kick your freaking
virtual self out of the chat all right
so just just
go easy go easy all right
um i'll do the i'll do the best i can
constantly looking over here
um onseno i see
you thank you very much you guys are
awesome
thanks for joining and um
yeah last last bit of announcements here
i'm going to be away next week i'm going
to yosemite for some camping um
with a couple of the guys from corridor
so we're going to be chilling
doing some film photography and camping
so i will not be live streaming next
week but i will be dropping a video for
you
guys about um how to get true motion
blur out of after effects
you know if you if you just toggle the
motion blur option you're gonna get some
like
faded out motion blur and it's not not
the best it can be
and it's actually something that i
learned from andrew kramer when he came
to the corridor studios
and he taught us this quick tip like
right off the cuff and it blew my mind
and i want to i want to teach you guys
that as well
so that's gonna be next week's video
it's a very short video probably five
ten minutes tops but um it'll definitely
up your after effects game if you guys
are using after effects all right
without further ado um
let's jump in oh you got that fight
sepwin got the 5am club audiobook very
interesting i like how they make it
almost a novel
yeah it's interesting i've never read a
self-help book before that was
kind of had a fictional story to it with
characters
so that's it's very interesting a little
cheesy at times but
interesting okay so we want to create
this
photo um the first the first thing that
that has
that has stumped me with octane is
interior
lighting when it comes to a very dark
space um it's very it
gets very grainy very quick and we're
gonna have to try and figure that out
um but we'll figure that out once we get
to the lighting step all right
um and and last little bit here i know
that you guys all submitted
your weekly challenge the the prompt was
aquatic we're gonna go over
all of those submissions well we're
gonna go over the five winners
at the end of this lesson okay so stick
around for that as well
i'll also be announcing the this week's
challenge
so okay like five false starts let's
begin so we need to we need to model
this this room here um
and i feel like an easy way of doing
this would be
to bust out just like a cylinder and
we're gonna
we're gonna get it going on plus x
and let's zoom in here um and and again
guys if you're using
blender or whatever you can do this as
well we can follow along here all right
um all right so it looks like it has
eight sides one two
three four five six seven eight right
so we'll do segments um
rotation we'll go eight
and we wanna rotate this so
that it's just kinda flat on the bottom
and there's probably some math involved
to get this exactly right
um
what would that be it's like 180 divided
by four
is that right how many like degrees
would we need to rotate this
22.5 perhaps
22.5 i think that's perfect sweet
so i'm gonna make uh i think we can get
rid of our height segments for now
i'm gonna hit c or you can press this
button up here we'll make this editable
and the first thing i'm gonna do is go
to polygon mode
and just get rid of these end caps i
probably could have checked the box to
exclude caps but we're we're good
next thing i want to do is scale up
these sides here
i also have to reverse my normals so
let's do that real quick because we're
going to be inside of this tunnel
right so ctrl a and reverse
normals ur and i want to try and learn
that shortcut i don't use it enough
um but now we can see that our normals
are correct you see that orange
highlight versus the blue the orange is
what you want that's going to make sure
that our textures and our
and our bump and our normals are all
going in the right direction
[Music]
all right next let's grab these sides
i'm gonna hit t
to go to our scale tool but you can see
it's being scaled all wonky right there
hit w that's gonna change your gizmo to
world orientation right
so we're gonna scale these up but we
want these to maintain that 45 degree
vibe alright so is there a way if i
select all of these
can i just
hmm what's the best way to do this i'd
have to like
scale this exactly so if i scale this up
let's see let's go to object axis
coordinates i want to scale this
what is this at this is at 13.91
let's try taking it to 20
and this will be 20 as well oh
so this needs to be 20 ah it's going off
axis
and so was that okay
all right so i think i need to adjust
my gizmo you see how if i go local
orientation it's all askew like that
because we've rotated it
so what i'm going to do is use the axis
center tool
actually no i don't need to do that i'm
going to just enable the gizmo here
and reset this back to zero so now our
gizmo is back
to properly proper orientation so let's
grab these again hit t for scale
and scale this up and now when i type in
20 it shouldn't affect any of the other
angles
and i'm just going to hit 20 for all of
these even the top and the bottom and
uh it'll be z here
and that ensures that these are all
being scaled
correctly so that these angled
wall panels maintain their perfect 45
degree angle i think we can probably go
like
22 on these just based off the reference
image
i'm just doing it by by eye here
now they kind of bow out and i was
looking up
pictures reference pictures online and i
believe this is called a wind tunnel
if you look closely there's a little jet
right here so this is
a wind tunnel and specifically
i know it is a japanese wind tunnel
because the photographer is japanese
and he takes photos of a bunch of
different
industrial areas in japan so
i'm looking on google right now and i'm
trying to find
this specific tunnel
and i found it before the stream
i don't want to spend too long on this
japanese wind tunnel photo maybe
and then you got to search by uh color
search by orange
and i still
can't find it and i don't want to waste
any more of your guys's time
here um
one last little check
and it's all good we'll we'll continue
to do it by eye here
no problem okay so they kind of bow out
a little bit
so i think what we could do is do a ring
selection i'm gonna hit ul
and grab all right that's a loop
selection rather
i'm gonna grab all those and
i'm wondering if we hold
ctrl
right so i hit e and that's going to
bring up the uh the move tool
hold ctrl and we're just going to make
these different segments and i'm just
going to scale them
up as we go
and it i'm a hold ctrl again
e and it's it's basically opening up
like a funnel
just like this and then i'll do one more
and really just open it up like that
and the air basically comes in from this
larger area and it's forced into this
tinier area and that's how you get a
nice
like wind tunnel effect if you've ever
gone between two buildings in an
alleyway
and you feel this breeze that's because
the wind is being
forced into a smaller area
and that's kind of the effect here so
we'll probably want to do
a bit of symmetry on this so we we want
to get this exactly right on the other
side so
what i'm going to do is hit kl and i
believe that is the
knife tool or no it's the loop path cut
and by holding shift it'll snap it to
different parts
of your your edge here or of your your
your surface
and right down the middle that should be
zero zero and if i
go to point mode select all these points
they should be zeroed out on the x yep
position yeah zero dot right there so
i'm gonna delete these points
and now it's starting right at 0 0
right at the origin so that means if i
were to hold alt
and throw it into a symmetry modifier
it's going to duplicate it right there
on the origin point
and that sets us up for doing a little
bit less work which is nice
if i throw the symmetry into a turbo
smooth
it does one thing we like and one thing
we don't like based off of the reference
you can see the smooth gradual um
kind of roll-off here right
and we're getting that here but
it's very very angular when you look at
it down the barrel
and the turbosmooth definitely
you know smoothed it out a little bit
too much for us so i found out from you
guys actually that if you hit q you can
toggle the subdivision surface on and
off
and we're going to make some cuts all
right
so ul is loop uh
loop selection oh no no um
kl kl is what we want with the cylinder
selected
we're going to make some cuts down the
barrel of this thing okay
so we basically want to just make some
cuts like
right in here really tight
and if you toggle the uh the subdivision
surface back on i'm hit
n a or no nb hold on
i was right the first time n a you see
how it brings that cut
it sharpens it up a whole bunch that's
because we made some cuts along
that little bit there so i'm just going
to do this all the way around
kl zoom in
make those tight cuts
and technically we can do another
symmetry
um on this so that we duplicate it from
the left side to the right side as well
but these cuts take like two seconds
so we're going to get in there and make
those cuts and you'll see
that when i zoom out here and turn my
subdivision surface back
on it's going to be nice
and angular and smooth at the same
time which is exactly what we want
wait what just happened there
a little bit easier to see this way
wait what what is going on
sweet
there you go so it's smooth um
coming down this ramp but it's angular
when looking at it down the barrel
like this which is exactly what we want
based off of the reference
um so how's everybody doing in the chat
so far you guys following along
um if you guys are part of the discord
server it's a place
for all of you guys to to hop in and
share ideas get feedback with
the community and it's also a place
where
i post challenges for you and also in
this case
i got this reference image posted for
you guys in the announcements
channel in the discord server so if you
guys want to follow along you can
you can do that as well probably should
have mentioned that earlier on but hey
it's all good so yeah thumbs up if you
guys are doing okay
and we'll keep going
oh steven what's up dude steven created
a really cool lego model of me
um i shared it on my instagram
and uh he's texturing that right now
heck yeah dude thanks for joining
it totally cool if you guys are just
like working on your own stuff too
um that's the whole that's the whole
thing is like even if you're working on
you know whatever it doesn't have to be
this lesson but
as long as we're hanging out and we're
working together on our passions like
that's chill super cool
all right so yikes back in
um the next biggest
thing here that i'm seeing are these
light panels
up in here um as well as this like
maintenance hatch this viewing window
um so let's start working those in okay
um and also let's get a figure in here
just to see how big this
is let's get it to scale okay
so what i'm going to do is grab the
subdivision surface
and i'm going to move the gizmo down
to this point here
something like that okay and we'll
uncheck
the gizmo option and we'll we'll
adjust the position to zero right so
it's sitting on the floor now that's the
origin point and i'm gonna hit t
and scale this thing up we know that
this person
is probably that big in this
chamber
something like something like that right
so now our scale is correct um it just
helps with
lighting it makes it a bit more accurate
okay
and we can also adjust oh
i'm crashing and i didn't save yet
oh no oh no
that was close guys that was close
let's save this out
this is episode 28 i think it's actually
like episode 30 or something
which is crazy we've done 30 of these
together maybe even more
that's super cool um you guys have
really kept me accountable
and have helped me grow my channel over
the last six months
it's really been very satisfying very
it's a cool feeling it's a very cool
feeling so thank you guys for coming
back time and time again
um so yeah we can you know we're going
to get our angle down here something
like this let's let's just bring a
camera in here
so i got my octane camera button set up
real easily there
if you guys want to make your own custom
buttons you can hit shift c
type in anything you want drag it and
you'll see that little
line there you can drag and drop there
make your own custom buttons you'll just
have to go to window customization
and you'll have to save it as a layout
otherwise when you open c4d again
it's gonna it's not gonna be there all
right
so what is this this is probably like a
24 maybe
a 35 hard to tell
but but he's in here and the original
image is actually framed a lot
differently because
this is just a small little picture
um of this image of the full image
and let me actually show you guys the
whole thing i got it from this book
it's called deep inside
and i think i've shown this before on
the stream
but basically it's a collection of joe
nishi ishizawa
yeah joe nishizawa's photography
and it's just some sick photography
of like underground tunnels and stuff
um just beautiful stuff
i don't know what i'm turning to but i'm
sure it's gonna be awesome
um yeah his work is incredible
so i pulled it from this book
page 36.
this is the full image
so the framing is really really cool um
but uh we'll we'll work in the framing
as we complete this thing
but if you guys want that book i think
it's available on the amazon it's called
deep inside by joe nishizawa
absolute like incredible
source of reference and inspiration i
have a whole lot of art books up here
and i use them just for that like for
inspiration i like to collect art books
that feature very unique locations
um versus just you know downloading
images on google
i like to have it in the book form
because i can just bust them out and
like sit down on the carpet and
open them up and and just get really
inspired
feeling it touching the page i just love
it
so yeah i always use reference and art
books are a great way to collect a lot
of cool different reference styles
okay so i know we don't see the floor
we're at a lower angle
something like this and
the i'm gonna hide the grid so we can go
filter
work plane and that gets rid of the grid
um and once we get some lights in here
it'll the shading will kind of go away
but
yeah let's hop out of the camera and
let's get these light
fixtures going okay
so let's go to the cylinder we can turn
off the subdivision surface
and
let's see here so this is
our live side and again since this is
symmetrical it is on both sides so maybe
what i'll do
i'll i'll do um another bit of symmetry
here i'm actually going to cut it down
the middle
so kl holding shift will get us right in
the middle there
boom all right and i'll do the same
on the bottom
and i'm going to let's just hide the
camera so that's this first little
stopwatch at the top
that little light let's grab all of this
the the vert vertices on the left side
or the right side doesn't matter but we
just want it to be cut right down the
middle just
like that and we want to make sure that
this is at zero
zero basically
i'll show you real quick so let's go to
that symmetry
holding down alt i'm going to drop
another bit of symmetry on it
but instead i'm going to get the mirror
plane is set to z
y let's try
x z no z no z x y yeah there it is x y
cool
now there's this hairline okay here this
is this is perfect this proves the point
there's this hairline little break here
down the middle okay
so if we select the original cylinder
and
we get all of these vertices down the
middle
or what is supposed to be the middle
holding shift to get those top ones
and if i move them you see how it opens
up you want it to be right at zero zero
okay so that they meet right in the
middle
so z should be set to zero and now
there's no hairline little
little piece i'm betting that was set to
like point one before
uh yeah it was 0.081 so we just want to
make sure that's zeroed out
and then it'll be a solid object so now
when we mess with our cylinder it's all
about doing less work right
saving ourselves as much time as
possible if we go to
polygon mode and we zoom in here if we
do any edits
on this plane it's going to be affected
on all sides it'll be duplicated here
and behind us because it's it's a
symmetrical
chamber that we're creating all right so
let's make some cuts
or some insets
kl holding shift that'll take us to the
50
mark let's make a cut there and i'm
going to
make one additional cut and that almost
does it for us
we can click away and let's grab
what's the best way to do this
i think if i just grab all of these
i don't feel like that's not gonna work
um let me undo
and see if i can't like open these up a
bit more
so kl again holding shift okay that gets
us right in the middle
make that cut and then i think the
distance
yeah okay so but we want to affect both
of those cuts
so number of cuts is two
and the distance i wish these could move
yikes all right now they're
crisscrossing
a little bit of experimentation we want
two cuts
proportional edge distance maybe what is
that
oh that's cool it like sticks to one
edge
we'll set it to proportional again
okay so maybe what we can do is just
type in the manual numbers
okay so
we'll go right down the middle
we want two cuts now this line
that we have selected
can be
offset uh maybe like
25 percent and then the second cut
can be 75.
that way this
light basically you can see how it's
it's thicker
down the middle than it is on the sides
so if you were to duplicate this light
move it down
and get this top border to this bottom
border it's going to go beyond that wall
so i'm just trying to get my proportions
correct right so that is actually
a perfect cut we have right here
and you can see hopefully if we were to
like you know extrude this
it's going to be affected on all sides
right and i want to make this a little
easier to see so i'm going to
toggle um let's toggle
the ambient occlusion in here so just so
we can see a little bit better
i think what is it alt v
yeah alt v we're going to go to filter
and if we scroll down we should be able
to
find oh and it's under effects
right in here and then we can actually
mess with the power of this we can just
set that to like five or something
if we want it to be really intense all
right so
this is the midpoint right here this is
the midpoint right here
we don't want this to go all the way
over so i'm just going to make another
cut
probably in here somewhere
and this can always be adjusted later
but now what we'll do is we'll just
do a little bit of offsetting in setting
let's move in here
and i am going to
extrude this back
so it's getting pushed back into the
wall
actually you know what i'm going to
extrude inner first
so we'll do mw
and then mt for extrude we'll push them
back
oh but you know what here's another
thing
we need to make a couple cuts down here
to
to basically let's see let's do like
two cuts that's perfect yeah because
these are gonna be our little windows
or our little like light fixtures
like right in there um
so we'll do mt to extrude enter
sorry mw
but notice we actually want to uncheck
preserve groups because we want these to
be our little individual window panels
mt for extrude that's going to push
those
back just like that
that gets us our our lights here
and then maybe an actually maybe another
thing we can do
to make this a no no that's fine i think
that looks really good
so you can see how it's duplicated on
all sides now
that totally works out and we can adjust
this later and it
was totally editable because we have
that symmetry set up and it makes it
really easy
um actually the last thing i'm going to
do
is just make sure this end one here
we're going to extrude this
enter again mw and then mt to come back
out
and we always want to bevel our edges
but we'll do that at the end okay
yeah that works out we'll go again
i just want to get that detail because
the lighting is really going to be
pretty sweet here and you want the
lights to bounce off the edges of things
and the more edges there are for the
lights to bounce off of it's going to
look
nicer
yeah that's cool
because that's like our black panel here
right
and then lastly um ooh
christian what's up thanks for the super
chat brother um christian asks favorite
sci-fi film mine is blade runner 2049.
that is an incredible movie i love blade
runner 2049
thought it was better than the original
um favorite sci-fi movie
the matrix probably um
i watched sunshine again recently that
was a really good one probably not my
favorite alien is really really good
the thing i don't know if you'd consider
that sci-fi
kind of sci-fi horror but that's
probably one of my favorites the 80s one
um other sci-fi movies that i love
i thought edu tomorrow was really good
children of men
is it's like light sci-fi
but it's incredible um
a rival was incredible same director as
blade runner
2049 lots of good ones guys
lots of really good ones okay i just
want to add one more bit of detail in
here
so this let's see
i want to grab what's the best way to do
this
so like these bits here
i basically want to hmm
maybe it's everything along here so i'm
trying to figure out a way to make like
a moat
[Music]
there we go so i have all of that
selected
and i want to maybe i have to do it with
cuts again
kl i'll go one here
one there and then one
there cool so now
if i go u y to extrude
i basically want to unso or deselect
everything that
isn't that little like moat section
and it might be easier for me to just go
in here and manually select
these bits i'm holding shift to
select multiple polygons here
and this will actually allow me to
extrude so mt
and i'm going to just push this back
and inset that into the wall there and
now it kind of has like a ring
around those lights
perfect and we'll do something similar
for
the ceiling here so the ceiling that's
right in the middle
okay um so what we can do
is probably subdivide this little bit
come on
subdivide i think is us
yep we'll grab that guy and we'll just
push him back into the wall like that
now it's leaving this little like
this little plus thing that i do not
like at all
so i wonder if there's a way to get rid
of that
create caps no that's not going to do it
preserve groups no
yeah i don't know the best way to
to get rid of those
so maybe what we can do
is make a cube
and make this thing so thin you can
barely tell
it's popping out of the wall here i'm
gonna make it editable
if you guys have an uh a way to fix
that like little flimsy
little bit there another i don't know
the best way to describe this
this here this this nasty little like
leftover fin
do you think i can just delete these
polygons like this
yo that that works
i think uh i think that totally worked
i think we can do to the same the same
deal here
for these little guys these little these
little fins they're just they're not
good for business
they don't look nice they're not what we
want that's perfect no that's that's
perfect let's get rid of that cube
and this is still one chunk this is
still one piece of geometry that we're
just
shaping and molding um i feel like
this needs to be smaller this cube here
so what we can do is
grab let's see let's
grab this edge here
and let's just move it in a little bit
and you see how the symmetry is really
helping us out there
and we're going to move it in until it
hits like let's just call it 15.
that means we're going to need to grab
this one
here and move this in until the z
is 5 or until the x is 15. and that will
be a perfect square
we kind of have this weird vibe going on
here but i think
that is okay for now until it's not okay
but i think that's chill
we can always make it larger later
alright let's take a moment for the chat
here um thanks for stopping by guys
who's hanging out with us today who do
we got
any questions that you guys have too i'm
gonna scroll up here
and read uh punisher could you do a 3d
modeling challenge with ian
yes i would love to do a 3d modeling
challenge with ian
i think he would totally be down for
that um ian hubert
i've talked about him here on the stream
multiple times before he's incredible
such a talented dude um i want to do
i really really really want to do um
collaboration streams with people i want
to have people on
there's a concept artist who worked on
the last of us too
who i would love to have on while i
create an image and he gives me like
tips
and direction um on my style and on my
lighting and my framing
that would be so cool that'd be a like
i've talked to him on instagram a couple
times
he's a fan he's down but i hadn't asked
him about coming on the stream yet so
i think he'd be down i think that'd be
really cool
what's up everybody how's it going
yeah thanks for joining guys um thanks
for hanging out
yes we're trying to get captain
dissolution on vfx artist react
um he just lives all the way across
the united states on the other side so
next time he's in la
oh it's gonna happen elejo
thank you for the super chat he says do
you have any um stock photo
sites for cgi compositing
stock photo sites do you mean like um
stock images or do you mean like
textures
because there's texturehaven.com that
they have free textures
modelhaven.com they have free models
hdrihaven.com they got free hdris and
they're like top notch um
official thixo says punisher so
inspiring to see you shaping this one
object i find myself
bowling everything not using symmetry
etc adding just other objects yeah it's
a it's a fun quick way to work
um the symmetry method definitely takes
a lot of the
the pain and anguish out of 3d modeling
so
definitely use it when you can
have i watched akira in 1988 like the
anime oh yeah super good
one of my favorites the story is a
little weird i feel like the last third
of the movie
it gets a little confusing but um
clint and the corridor crew needs to
watch kung fury for vfx artifact that's
not a bad idea kung fury was pretty
sweet
i would agree i would totally agree you
guys are doing good man um
the chat seems really chill i don't know
if diran had to kick anybody
but i don't think i don't think he had
to
oh the symmetry knife what is the
symmetry knife
i had so much to learn so much to learn
um okay not not god says would you do a
tutorial in the future about
toon shading using arnold or octane
totally i've just
never messed with it i kind of just
stick to what i know
um and it's tough you know it's like for
me to be able to learn something new
they i have to take the time to learn
that thing you know what i mean
um and i'm learning a whole lot of
different stuff but
i tend to i want to keep this
entertaining for you guys and
educational for you guys
so i i tend not to like dive into stuff
i don't know too much
on the stream i know that um
uh chris schmidt has rocket lasso and he
does his
stand before these streams and he's like
he's constantly experimenting so he's a
really good resource too
if you guys are trying to learn more
about the technical side of 3d modeling
chris schmidt
is is the man
very very knowledgeable all right
let's um let's get the next little bit
here
um this viewing window which
maybe is on both sides it's probably not
on both sides
i'm guessing but i don't think we're
going to see that other side based on
the angle here
so um
is this when we make things editable no
not yet not yet
let's get these little grooves and
divots
in our jet stream here okay so we have
this one on the top
so let's let's knock that one out i'm
gonna take my cylinder and i'm actually
going to
undo that scaling that i did
all right i'm going to leave it that way
so i can get some uniform
cuts in here kl
we'll get in here kl that's our loop
path cut and let's go i'm holding shift
let's get that last notch there holding
shift let's get that last notch there
so they're lined up perfectly okay and
then i'm gonna zoom
in let's do right here let's get
that first notch and that first notch
so now what we can do is select
yikes what's happening
i don't understand
why
huh why is it selecting i don't know why
it's
hmm
yeah why is it why is it selecting uh
that's very strange whoa
okay okay okay okay i think it's because
i need to like i think i need to go all
the way
so kl um i want
for some reason it's skipping this
this little bit here
all right time to do some doctor work
here i'm going in
undoing these cuts i think it was a
subdivision that messed me up
yeah it was that subdivision that messed
me up
so i need to just make proper cuts
all the way down the line right there
okay so then now i'm going to go in
and let's let's do this top hatch proper
here
um we'll do mt
for extrude we'll extrude that up
notice it's going negative 0.5 inches
yeah not negative
negative 0.5 inches okay and then we're
going to extrude inner
a little bit
and we'll go 0.5 inches
we'll extrude it back to point
okay there we go there we go point five
all right sweet so now we have that like
moat and that's going to give us that
hard line
okay and now we're going to extrude
enter again
and we'll extrude negative
0.25 or negative 0.2
and that's like our paneling okay
and it's doing it to everything versus
just the hatch so maybe
that's the best way to do this
also why is there why are there two cuts
there
very confused
so i'm trying to keep it clean
what is it like not
yeah very confused
is my symmetry gone over
um no
should we should be fine
so when i set it to zero if i zoom in
let's get rid of the figure i just want
to make sure that this is proper um
oh it actually snaps that's cool
it snaps right in
let's set this to the negative z
no we'll undo that
and let's just come back in here and see
if
it's normal now yeah now we're good
i think i just had to make sure that my
symmetry was right on zero and snapped
together
all right so we've learned that we can
just delete
these little fins and that will clean up
our edges there so i'm probably going to
leave this
for now and come back in once
we make this editable let's let's finish
up the rest of our symmetrical
adjustments
okay and then we'll come in and do that
that detail adjustment that isn't
symmetrical
i'm going to make this outer ring again
we're getting back to it
we'll go there we'll go there so we made
our cuts
now
let's zoom in and hopefully
we're not going to have this issue now
where uh so one there
and one there
and it looks like that is actually a bit
more proper
we'll select these yup now that's normal
okay
so this is all problem solving all of 3d
modeling basically is just
problem solving
we'll get that holding down shift
we'll select that alright so that's
everything there
oh wait i did that wrong
again let's think about this
that's what we want that's definitely
what we want
there here
and here
sweet
so now when we extrude this
we go negative 0.75 inches
we should get a square
drawn around all of that yep
that works for me that makes sense it
looks a little rectangular
for some reason so i might have to
let's let's take care of these fins
first
and then we're going to bevel everything
at the end and it's going to
really make the edges catch the light
that's definitely something that you
guys want to do more of is
bevel your edges
just deleting these unwanted fins
there we go now it's if we filled that
up with water
the water would flow freely around
everything and then let's just adjust
um these two edges
we'll go into top view so we can
actually get an accurate representation
of what we're doing you can see it's a
little on the rectangular side
so i'll actually select
all of these here all of these straight
lines
and then we'll deselect these verticals
and then we'll just bring all of this
down
so it's more on the square side there we
go
and i guess it'd be the same for our uh
i don't know how that got rectangular on
us
we'll do the same here
we'll bring this down until
um it's a little little difficult to
tell what's going on there we go yeah
that's perfect
sweet
that looks really nice i like that a lot
okay back to the chat how are you guys
doing um yes riley i'm using a stylus
that's why my uh the pen looks all crazy
like this
it's because i'm moving around and
and going crazy i got the stylus here
it's a
wacom what is it wacom
uh intuos pro 4 it's the medium sized
one
i don't need anything big but it it
saves my wrist if i'm
basing my whole career off of this wrist
then you should probably
do the best thing you can for it right
and i heard that the
the the tablet saves all the wrist
saving that wrist
yeah hey and um definitely shout outs to
deerin mr dinklewinkle who is our first
chat moderator thank you so much and
he's actually dropping some helpful
links he said some of you guys are
asking quite in-depth questions please
visit the discord if you want to get
help with them
and he dropped a link to the discord in
the chat just scroll up a little bit
um and sas one says how did i
come to work at corridor i met sam and
nico along with freddie and brandon
about 10 years ago on youtube big fans
of them
and you know we helped each other out
they helped me out with a lot of vfx
stuff i learned a lot from
them i came out to visit visited them
and we just started playing video games
together
became good friends and when it came
time that corridor was hiring it just
made sense for me to join
that's the very quick version
all right let's finish out the symmetry
so let's get
this next little tab right here
right in there okay
so
looks like we have these two like it's
probably here
i'm thinking kl
and we'll make just a cut there
ul for loop selection and i'm just going
to hit mt
and extrude all of that
i feel like there's a way to do this
without creating those like little fins
i think preserve groups
there you go preserve groups was what we
needed
awesome so i'm going to go negative .75
on those
so they're really inset
and it looks so nice with the uh
oh shoot okay so you see when we turn
back on
the oh my goodness look at all these
so we kind of goofed up here we gotta
fix all this because we turned our
our turbo smooth on we need to make sure
that
see i wonder if i bevel the edges or
when we bevel these edges it'll fix that
so i'm going to try it real quick let's
try beveling these
these edges and see if that will fix our
subdivision surface because it's turning
these into like little port holes we do
not want that
so we just need to create more geometry
along the edges
to really ensure that they stay tight
okay so let's do let's drop
a bevel modifier
in somewhere within this hierarchy it's
probably going to be under
the bevel mod or under the subdivision
surface okay yeah
so we'll offset it by point one and
we'll zoom in here i'm gonna hit
n b to show our edges okay
and i should have done that long ago
it's a lot easier to see
um let's try 0.05 because we don't want
anything i want anything overlapping
like we might see in here right if you
if you push it too far like point one
it's gonna start overlapping and you're
gonna get issues
so we'll try 0.05
let's even go .025 for now and let's set
the
subdivision to three
and that is nice it really cleans things
up and it gives us gives our edges um
a lot of potential here because they're
going to catch light
and you're going to see that nice edge
you're going to see that swing it's
going to be great
let's work it in let's go point four oh
0.04
sorry that feels pretty good to me
that's about as far as we can push
that corner you're kind of limited to
your tightest corner
and we're getting some weird artifacting
here
um i wonder if there's a ways to fix
that probably in the fong
22.2 10
that will fix it 12
11 10 seems to get rid of that issue
but you don't want it too too intense
let's
bring our subdivision surface back in
hit n a and would you look at that
it's doing most of the work we need
now because our phone is so low we're
getting
this like step platformy kind of
effect we don't want that let's set it
to 11
12 and it's probably gonna be more like
22
23 and i'm just going to go up to 24 25
until it smooths out this last little
bit
so 30 does it 29
okay we can just probably
call it right at 30.
and that's going to smooth that out this
probably won't be an issue too big of an
issue
when we render but we'll see we we know
that it comes down to this phong
angle so if we set that to 10 it'll kind
of smooth things out
but yeah no the bevel totally um fixed
our issue if i turn the bevel back
off wait a second
why is it not doing it now is it even
subdividing
oh let's get this back up to 30.
i don't know why it's
if i get the bevel out of there yeah if
the bevel's out of there
we're getting this issue but even with
the bevel turned off if i drop it in
it fixes it is that because it's
subdividing the bevel and not the
symmetry
nobody is subdividing the symmetry i'm
very confused
interesting
so it's all about problem solving
i mean this this is what we want the the
ambient occlusion is a little intense
right now but this is certainly what we
want
maybe i'll set the uh the phone to 10
for now just so we can
clean up the way we're viewing this a
little bit more
okay um moving
on we let's see
we're close we're getting very very
close
to knocking this out
and this is all adjustable so if we want
to do a loop selection ul
right here
i would want to adjust this from the
midpoint so
i would move the anchor point
to zero on the z
and we would scale things down from
there
and that would just kind of tuck that in
a little bit
sweet
very nice very very nice
so i think
[Music]
what we'll do next i'll probably do one
more cut
with kl right along
this point here
and i'm gonna hit ul in edge mode
and then i'm going to extrude that in
again
negative 0.75
and it should automatically be beveled
the edge yup these are automatically
beveled which
is perfect it's just what we want
very cool so we have this cut
we have these cuts i don't think there's
any other cuts we need to make
this window is the last thing right
all right so i think we're in a position
where we can make this editable now
because we're going to get into
window detail and this hatch detail
which it's symmetrical but not
symmetrical
um the way we have it set up it's
symmetrical from left to right
but we have left right forward and back
symmetry as well so
i'm going to
[Music]
save this let's go ahead and control
drag the subdivision surface and i'm
just going to call this copy
so we're saving a state right now um
and you know what you know what i'll do
instead of doing that
i'm just going to save a new iteration
so episode 28
v2 so we can come back to that v1
um and just to make sure
i'll save that and back in
so if we ever need to come back to what
we're about to do here
we can i'm going to hit c on the
symmetry
and it's now one piece so i can get rid
of the symmetry
and we can do any edits we want we no
longer have symmetry set up
but that's okay i'm going to get rid of
the
ambient occlusion it's really chunking
up our viewport frame rate here
i mean our frame rate's a little chunked
anyway but that's okay
um
right so let's make this window
and make some cuts we'll do
one cut here we'll call it two
and we'll offset this to maybe
75 and the second
cut right there we'll call that 75 as
well
or negative 75. wait what's the best
let's try that again two cuts
one of them is at 75 percent
oh come on let's try it again holding
shift so we get right in the middle
boom
75 and maybe it's 25
trying to just select this piece right
there
that's 75
and i think that's correct so
our midpoint
is right let's let's get that figure
back in it'll kind of help us
determine our midpoint and we can move
him
up against the glass
i'm gonna hit nb so we can like see
our edges here so this is our midpoint
okay so my window
is a little bit smaller than the area
that the lights
span across so probably from here
to here will be our our viewing window
if it's if it's not exact that's fine
that is okay
alright so let's figure this out it
looks like the viewing window is
segmented in a couple different
um ways
so i'm i'm probably just gonna solo this
real quick
as in i'm gonna freehand the way
this thing looks
all right so let's make that moat
that window mode so we'll go negative
0.75 i'm going to extrude
enter and we want to preserve
groups we want this as one whole thing
and we'll extrude back out to 0.75 so
this is flush
with the wall now okay so now we have
like a little little inset frame
let's go ahead and inset this further so
mw for extrude inner
we'll scale that in so now we have
a window frame and now what i'll do is
i'll just select a couple of these
pieces
like that
that's cool and i'm going to extrude
those
so mt we'll push those back and this
will be
our window just like that
and technically there's stuff going on
in the window
but i don't think we need to model too
much of what's going on in the inside
for now at least
we can save that for later if we really
need to come back and
and work on that we can um
let's make sure our bevel modifier is
still working and it looks like
it is yep looks like it's doing a good
job
cool
i might just leave that
blank here um
it'd be nice to have a cross section so
maybe i will
make a cut like right in there
and i basically want two frames two
window frames
um on like the top and bottom third so
this
line here we can push to
75 percent yep and then we'll select
this one
and we'll push this to uh
twenty five percent
that way we kind of open up our our
viewing window
bits a little bit more um
alright so to make those actual
let's see problem solving problem
solving
i want some frames up here and some
frames down here
maybe something like that
and we can grab these guys
something like that and we'll do the
same down here
cool and then now
we should be able to push our window
portions
back into z space
so something like that
and just for um so we can visualize
what's happening
i'm going to
throw down a texture onto our windows
and our lights okay
awesome so now we can actually kinda see
what's going on and again we're having
some weird
deformations in our geometry because of
the bevel modifier
but
we probably don't have to worry too much
about that for now
we can always fix that later
and let's work on the detail of uh
of this little hatch up here so i'm
gonna grab
these guys up here
we'll extrude enter
extrude 0.5
and we'll extrude enter again
extrude up cool
and we can probably like it looks like
there's a pretty detailed piece of
geometry here in this hatch
we might be able to skip that
for now or do it with um
like just do it in the texture you know
what i mean
all right so it's almost time to light
and texture this thing
we are very very close um this plane
model we can probably bust out really
quick but let's get the lighting
down first okay i think we're there
so let's pick our angle probably
something
like this
cool and let's uh let's give it a render
this is what we got so obviously the
lighting is
very very different let's see if we can
get much closer
to the look that we see here okay so i
think the first thing
that we would want to do um is
get these guys lit up and get this
window lit up okay
so let's start with
these guys up here the first thing i'm
going to do
is create a
octane environment so an octane sky and
it's set
to black by default all right there's
nothing plugged in here
if we switch it to a color we can change
the color that the sky
is right but we just want it to be black
and then we want to plug in lights up
into
these little led panels so there's two
ways we can do this we can either
we can we can start with an emissive
texture
so let's just make a new
octane diffuse material
in your live viewer if you go to
materials you can create that
this way it's right at the top or you
can hit shift c
and type in diffuse you can search
anything in cinema 4d
with uh shift c it's really really handy
diffuse right
um but let's go into that diffuse and
we'll go to
medium now i mission i'm sorry
and we'll select black body emission
and that turns it into an emissive light
basically and it's set to
white temperature 6500 power 1000
i think that is all good all right so
what we'll do is we'll select our
cylinder and we just want to select
holding down shift all of these bits
here
that are counted as lights
i'm gonna come around this other side i
think i forgot
yep that bit and that bit
okay so we'll add that we'll just drag
and drop that on and now you can see
it kind of looks like star wars pretty
sweet it's
lighting up the interior of of
our uh uh what would you call it
wind tunnel yeah it's a wind tunnel
now as for the room instead of an
emissive i think what we can do is
actually
throw a glass specular material on here
so we'll do specular
and i'm going to select all
of these guys here
and we'll apply this glass material and
we're going to shine a light through
it okay so let's go ahead and
apply that material so it's glass now we
can see through it
let's go ahead and get rid of that
original material
and let's go ahead and create an octane
area light
we'll bring that right up to there scoot
it back
flip it around so it's a 180 degree
rotation
and we want to scale it up
so it fits the entire piece of the
window here
we'll bring it right up to that window
and we will
adjust the color temperature so let's
mess with our camera settings first okay
so let's go to camera
imager we'll check camera imager on
um none of these i feel like none of
these settings are gonna
work or change because we are set to
ace's linear
right now so i'm actually going to hop
out of that let's go
hdri
hdr tone mapped yeah
and i like kodachrome 25 that's a real
nice one we'll check neutral response so
it doesn't mess with the color
gamma will set the 2.2 and it's totally
looking like a star wars scene right now
pretty sweet
um let's so these
lights here are certainly tungsten
lights so let's change the color
temperature to
[Music]
4200
and i'm wondering if the walls
are i feel like the walls are
white it's hard it's hard to
tell like what are we white balanced for
because you have orange and blue in
sorry you have you have um orange and
blue
in this image so it's hard to tell what
we're color balanced for or
if these walls are just straight up
tinted you know like in that tungsten
color
um i feel like these guys
are white your white balance is here set
for their for their helmets and stuff
so maybe these walls are a bit on the
orange side
interesting let's let's grab a material
from qixel bridge and
see if we can't work in the lighting and
the feeling a bit more
okay
all right yeah this is gonna be nice and
shiny we gotta definitely make this
thing
shiny um so let's go to surfaces i'm in
quiksil
bridge a fantastic um
company quixil is incredible they've
changed the game
when it comes to 3d art on the internet
here
so we want
[Music]
is it other it's definitely shiny like
it's not it
i feel like it's like a a metal or a
plastic or something like it's not
marble
you know it's that shiny uh
is it concrete i feel like there's no
way it's concrete let's let's try metal
let's see what's up here in metal
we want uh treated
metal enamel sheet
something like this like that's that's
close
that looks interesting so
let's favorite it okay and i'm just
going to keep scrolling down and see
what we can find we want something
with some warped kind of uh
normal texture here there's definitely
some imperfections going on so we want
to find something that isn't too
clean
all right enamel sheet that's
interesting um let's let's keep
going painted metal perhaps
this is all scratch we don't want
anything too scratched up
sheet metal
we also might be able to find something
in plastic
so let's let's try um
they don't have they don't have plastic
let's just try other let's see what
we have in other
oh like honestly like this isn't bad
right here we won't be able to mess with
that
i'll favorite that
oh japanese tatami mats that's super
cool
like fur animal creature skin let's type
let me just try
uh type in plastic
under surfaces
and see what we can find
then we might we might have to just mess
with we're probably going to tweak
something we might not be able to find
the perfect
material here
like these these tiled um
materials aren't bad they're very shiny
we want something that's very shiny
i'm probably going to go with the
original that we have
and mess with the parameters on that
and we can push the normal maps and
everything too
so let me try that i'll go back to our
favorites
enamel sheet okay and let's make sure
uh download settings 8k absolutely
let's download it
if you guys have any questions feel free
to ask right now this is a good time to
answer questions while things are
downloading
long shot digital okay how can you plan
ahead for vfx
during a shoot that's a good question
um it'd be actually pretty sweet to do a
whole
whole video on vfx supervision
that just comes from experience from
doing vfx shots so many times
that you have pulled your hair out
enough
that when you're on set you'd be like
hey i've been in this position before
and i hated working on that shot because
you know you didn't put down
tracking markers or because you know you
had some foreground element that could
have been easily added later
but you decided to just put it in there
because it's like part of the shot no
get rid of it we'll add it in later as
opposed to having to roto it out
so that just comes from experience doing
vfx supervision
the more shots you do the more you'll
know how to shoot something
for vfx you just have to get out there
and shoot
get out there shoot your shots do your
vfx
um and uh
we'll all be more educated you know all
right so let's um
let's export this guy favorites
and if i just hit export it's actually
going to just pop
right into my scene here in cinema 4d
which is super cool
we'll export that see what happens
um tips for photo realism just
experimenting more um surya is asking
yeah um definitely use reference
use reference that's probably the most
important element
i've put out two videos now on
recreating a photo
like a very close-up photo i have the
one of the doorknob and then i have the
one
of like the the phone booth keypad
and i recreated those images as closely
as possible to match
the reference image and
the main thing is the reference like
without that reference i wouldn't have
been able to do it
of course lighting comes into play you
you want to
include details you want to bevel your
edges there's no such thing as a
perfectly
sharp edge everything is beveled and
it's going to catch the light in a very
nice way but i'd say the most important
thing for photo realism is to use
reference and constantly check back and
forth to see
if your render is matching that
reference
and if it's not what needs to change you
just need to ask yourself those
questions
but let's go back in and let's throw a
texture down on this guy
so
let me select everything except
for
certain bits here um
what's the best way to do this okay i
know i know
we wanna we want to apply the material
to the walls but not the lights or this
little ceiling tile
and we can come in here and deselect all
this by hand but that's gonna that's not
gonna be
easy for anybody what we'll do is we'll
select all the parts that
aren't the wall that we're going to be
texting and then we'll invert our
selection
so let's go ahead and
select just the faces
of pieces that aren't the wall
right just the faces
and it's a little bit more difficult now
because
um we don't have symmetry going on so
our
selection is going to take a little bit
longer but that's okay and i'm actually
going to start
with these little bits here on the side
i'm holding down shift
let me pause the render and i'm going to
grow the selection
so i'm gonna hit u y a couple times
all right and then i'm gonna select this
bit i'm gonna hit u y
a couple more times and that almost
gets us to where we need to be and let's
select these last
lights here and we're going to hit uy
which is gross selection we're going to
hit it a couple more times and we should
have
everything selected that isn't the walls
or that aren't the walls we'll get all
of that okay i'm going to hit uy
a couple more times and i was one off
but that's not bad
and that gets us right in there
that's where we want to stop okay so i'm
just going to inspect down the line
and it looks like we need to
select those bits there
we left one of those uh
those little flaps there but that's okay
for now we'll zoom in just
make sure we have everything selected
that isn't our wall
and then we're going to invert the
selection okay so
doing a scan holding shift and getting
all the bits that we missed
and we probably went overboard on the
roof if i had to guess
we did so i'm holding ctrl and i'm just
going to deselect all that that's easy
right
sweet
and the window we forgot the window so
let's see um let's go into side view
now i'll stay here and with my selection
tool selected
i'm going to go to i'm going to uncheck
only select visible
so i'm just going to hold shift and just
do a run
basically around all of this
and that's going to select everything
it doesn't matter if we can see it or
not it's going to select
all of the geometry that our mouse is
washing over
now we're probably going to again get in
here and like
grab these bits yikes don't do that
again a little bit more tedious because
of the lack of symmetry here
but that's okay this image symmetry
saved us a lot of time
it did its job well
getting everything
so this isn't the entertaining part is
it this isn't why you guys join the
stream is it
to watch me just select things
over and over and over because that's no
fun
but i hope you guys are having a good
time because i know i'm excited to see
how this final image turns out so now
okay look
we did it i'm going to set a selection
boom just so we can save that we saved
our work um
let's go ahead and invert the selection
so that's u
i that's going to invert the selection
now
we have successfully selected everything
except those bits and you know what i
feel like it'll be faster
to just do this the other way by
selecting all this but hey we learned a
thing today
so that's all right and let's go ahead
and drag and drop
our material that we got from bridge
onto our
walls let's render it and see what it
looks like it looks
absolutely horrible what
is happening well don't worry guys
because i got the fix for you
we're going to go in to the material
let's set it to glossy
and we'll set it to octane let's go into
the node editor
and see what the heck is wrong all right
i'm going to drop this here
and it has to do with the way it's being
wrapped around our geometry
okay and you can always fix that with a
projection node
in octane i know redshift has very
similar stuff
it's right in here projection and we'll
pipe this in
to all of the different textures
cool
and we'll just set it the box and that's
going to clean it up
and if let's just get a little bit more
light in here so we can see
um what our material actually looks like
so i'm going to change that
to white and maybe get rid of
our lights and
turn our emissive off so it cleans up a
lot faster
and that doesn't look uh half bad in
terms of mapping goes like we're going
to mess with the
the attributes here but that's not
that's not the worst
yeah not half bad okay so there we can
see we have some issues
um
and maybe there but who knows maybe we
just maybe we just get rid of that in
photoshop
you know you know what i mean
okay that's cool um
let's see if we can get some nice
specular detail out of this so
we'll turn the bevel ooh okay see what i
mean right here so we got bevel on
we actually i think what we need to do
is probably get in there
and uh
throw down like a black material on the
inside of there
but let's go ahead and turn our lights
on let's get our
octane sky back to black
and we'll turn our lights back on
admission
back on cool all right now what we'll do
is we want to get these highlights
that you see here in the reference we
really want those to pop okay
so what i'll do here
is let's go ahead and make
our live viewer a little bit larger
okay
i feel like this is a little too angled
i want this to to bow
more like our reference
so i think i'm going to just open this
up we still have those edges selected
that's great
i'm going to go ahead and bring this z
to zero
and scale it up
but it looks like we need to select a
couple more things so let's go
ul and then i'm gonna hit u y
i don't know why it's going beyond like
that
ul
holding ctrl that takes us to the edges
and let's hit u y again and that gets us
what we need okay
and then we'll deselect these bits
and these bits
and now we should be able to scale this
up
with our gizmo at zero on the z
oh we need everything that's right
because we don't
uh we're not doing symmetry anymore
all right
so bear with me we're gonna get those
we'll go up here we've got these little
flappies
we want to get rid of
get rid of those and it looks like
there's a seam down the middle
of our structure
we'll deal with that in a minute
let's go u y
and that's going to select everything uh
loop selection
holding control we'll go to edge mode
and we'll hit u
y again or no i'm sorry not u y
or maybe i was right
yeah u y is going to grow our selection
and we'll deselect all this
very tedious isn't it that's 3d for you
guys
got to put in the time
to get that desired effect the more you
do it the faster you'll get
so now we have
that look we want so i can come in here
and you can see it kind of rolls off the
edge a bit more
which is a little closer to
a reference
like just like that
okay so let's let's hop into our uh
our texture here and adjust the
speculars so let's do
[Music]
a little bit render region there so we
can see
our reflection let's hop into the
material
and mess with
believe it's going to be our roughness
let's take the bump let's get rid of it
yep
so the normal is certainly getting us oh
that's beautiful
you see that that's really doing a good
job
let me show you guys
the detail in here that the normal is
getting us it's exactly what we want
you see this wall right here this is it
this is totally it and that's coming
from the normal map i disconnected the
bump
because it was fading out our
reflections i got rid of the
roughness map which is washing out our
reflections and i'm just leaving it to
the normal
and the specular if i get rid of the
specular
okay that's insane all right let's not
even let's not even go there
let's put the specular back in that's
doing a pretty good job
i like that a lot um
let's go to the albedo and that is
our actual color channel
we can adjust the contrast to bring out
a bit more texture into this thing
and we can also take the normal and
crank the normal as well
so let me go back to one here
and maybe point eight
and the main thing that i'm seeing here
this there's a lot of bounce light
happening inside of this chamber okay
and our image is it feels
pretty dark um so we we really need to
liven up this space here okay
so i think the way we can do this a
couple different options we can either
take our emissive texture
and the temperature we can set to
uh i think we can leave it but maybe
we take the power and we set it to like
300
or 500 and we can take the power
of our light
let's see of our octane light
and we can maybe bring this up to 200.
what if we did a thousand all right
that's that's pretty intense
i feel like there's more lights
lighting this up it looks like there's
some under light going on here
it's hard to tell maybe it's just the
bounce light happening
um but maybe we can mess with
um let's take down this back to 200.
yeah it looks like there's light a light
source from underneath the scaffolding
it is hard to tell
maybe maybe there's little like
spotty lights underneath that's helping
generally like lift the scene so maybe
what we could do
is throw down
like an array of
circular area lights so if i bring this
guy out
right and i
rotate it 90
and instead of a rectangle we can set it
to
a a disc
scale it way down and the reason why i
say that look at these look at the
reflection up here
you see this dot dot dot dot it's very
faint but it might be coming down from
down on the floor
i'm also seeing these dot dot dot right
here
i think that's the reflection
of lights on the ground i could be wrong
but let's just see what it does for us
okay
um
i'm gonna change the temperature to 4200
let's give it um
let's move it back here okay
i'll push it back to this point
and then i'm just gonna give it uh
i'm gonna clone it so holding alt i'm
gonna throw in the cloner
it's automatically set to grid array
let's set it to linear
we don't want it going in the y
direction we want it going
in the x negative x direction
we can get an end point we'll find our
end point
probably right there and we'll set it to
end point
and then we can just do a count of like
10
along that little bit okay
and then what we could do is probably
take that cloner
we can set the gizmo
to zero uh is that working
let's try that again we'll set the gizmo
to zero that that doesn't work
um
maybe we'll just
duplicate it why is that not working
there we go
so that's certainly livening up
the interior space and i can take both
of these
and set it to like 200 and that
really starts to
bring out that interior space most
definitely
now i think these lights up here
are a bit intense um
[Music]
because our reflections are a little
crazy right now
but we're getting there i'm going to
hide the figure
for now
and i definitely want to adjust the back
here i want to see the back fall off
versus cut off
so let's adjust the lights first okay
actually in in camera what we can do is
crank the highlight compression
and that will actually save us
save a bit of our highlights okay
um and maybe if we get our angle
low enough
that's looking pretty cool i'm starting
to starting to dig this
okay um one thing i'm noticing is
we have a light here or something that's
probably not textured
let me go to uh bridge real quick
because i tend to get a little
distracted here but let's go to
decals i think
metal decals
um
and we can probably find some sort of
grating
here that we like
like maybe maybe this this drain
or even this rusty metal metal utility
cover
is cool
but let's go with the drain because it's
uh
it's a bit more uniform okay
so let's go ahead and download this
4k is fine let's download
and let's find like a like a dark metal
texture because that's gonna light or
that's gonna be like uh
the framing on the windows and up in
here
okay so let's do um
let's go back to surfaces we can do
a metal surface or you know what
i think i'm just going to use grayscale
gorilla's everyday materials pack for
that it's a lot faster
so let's go to materials and open the
live db viewer
if you guys are unfamiliar grayscale
gorilla they release a ton
of really awesome cinema 4d plugins
that are super handy i use them all the
time
and they have one in particular called
the everyday materials pack
all right so if we go to medals
we have a whole bunch here and i think
they're made by chad ashley
he is one of the masters no doubt
big fan of his work let's uh
open this up a little bit more and we'll
just find like a dark
metal that we can use like any like
probably this gun metal
um down here rusted metal
steel where's where are you gunmetal i
know you're in here somewhere
gunmetal like right in here we can try
that
definitely we definitely want something
dark
let's go with that so i'm going to right
click it and just download
that material
cool
and i need to select all my frames okay
so let's um
pause the renderer and let's go through
here let's go through the cylinder
and select all of the frames okay
everything that's going to be that that
gunmetal texture okay
um ul is going to be our loop selection
and it's a little intense right now so
i'm going to hit uh
nq to turn off textures and then i think
n c yep we'll turn off our lights
so we can see a little bit better
and i'm just going to select
[Music]
these frames here holding shift to
select the frames
it's going to get all of that good stuff
i got to do it again on the other side
but i also need to do it here on
the windows
so i just want to do like a uniform
selection
and then i'm going to grow that
selection okay
all right so hit u y
yep about there let's see if our window
is okay
and it went into our window but that's
okay we'll deselect the window bit
and we want to go one we want to go
one more on the window okay so now i'm
going to hold ctrl
and deselect the actual window pane
it looks like i oh only only select
visible elements
we want that checked because we don't
want to accidentally uh
uncheck anything
so we certainly need to deselect
all of these extra bits here and i'm
going to turn
only select visible elements i'm going
to uncheck that again just to make sure
we do want to deselect everything here
ctrl shift z will undo camera moves
and i'll do the same on this side we
want to deselect stuff that we don't
want
all the way down the line and on the top
side too
cool
and i'm going to hit ul
i think that's fine if we don't get the
inside of that that's okay
i will save these little pieces for
later
all right but i'm gonna save the
selection set the selection you can do
that by going to select
and set selection right there cool
all right and now
what we can do is drag and drop this
gunmetal
oh wait before i do that before i do
that definitely want to deselect the
lights
if we don't want gunmetal lights we want
light lights
cool so we just want the frames
sweet all right so then we will set that
selection all right that's our
that's the selection we want and we'll
call it frames
now let's drag and drop and that gun
metal if i render
is going to be over top everything let
me turn off the lights for a second
so we can see a little bit better what's
going on
and if we get real close to it we notice
the mapping is off again
so let's go back in
and we'll do the same thing i always do
this make a projection node
pipe it into projection
and set it to box you guys will learn so
much by doing things over and over and
over again
the repetition is crucial to learning
anything new
um your brain doesn't quite get it yet
and you need to do it over and over for
it to kind of lock in
so the more you do it like certainly the
way i learned octane
is through um octane jesus david are you
or david arya if i'm
not a little confused in the last name
but
he's octane jesus you know he knows
everything about octane so i learned a
whole bunch from him
and watching his tutorials over and over
again i learned a whole lot
because he would repeat certain things
and those eventually got ingrained into
my mind because i watched them over and
over again
and he's using them in different
contexts too so
definitely um yeah
definitely do it over and over again
because then you'll learn you'll
absolutely learn
and melanie hey what's up good to see
you thank you for the super chat
very very kind very generous of you
thank you so much
um he says hey hey there or she says
hello there hope you are doing well
i saw the film development video you got
such great photos with your film camera
thank you
melanie um yeah so if you guys don't
know
i'm over at corridor digital that's my
full-time job the day job
we make awesome stuff over there and on
corridor crew me and nick developed our
own
film photos that was a trip
an absolute blast and
nick developed black and white film and
i developed color film
and it was it was quite the trip yeah um
i learned a whole lot and cannot wait to
continue developing my own film
i'm actually probably going to get a
scanner soon so i can get
much higher quality scans and a lot
better
color results out of that camera
but okay back in
ronin good question okay and what cases
do you do box projection and in what
cases do you do an actual precise uv
unwrap
so i am not the best when it comes to
texture
wrapping i just know that when it comes
to box
in octane or like cubic um in c4d it
basically just lays it flat
across your image um the uv
wrapping is kind of when you when your
model has a uv tag on it like if you
download something from turbosquid and
it comes
with like or even if you download it
from bridge
and you go to like uh 3d assets
you're going to get um a model
you're going to get geometry right and
then you're going to get like five or
six
different um texture images
that make up the look of this model here
and the model comes with
a uv tag on it and that's when you
wouldn't touch the projection
you would just drop the texture
images onto you know your material you
drop
your material onto the surface
and the uv tag is going to make sure
that it is properly wrapped
you don't have to worry about it but
when it comes to like custom stuff here
in c4d or blender or maya whatever
there's gonna be times where you have to
unwrap it or not unwrap it but change
the projection to more of like a flat
evenly distributed
projection right so that's what box is
in c4d
or octane particularly but that metal
looks good to me
that bevel is giving us that white edge
and we don't want that so i'm wondering
if we can just add like a
maybe we won't be able to tell from this
distance like
maybe if we're lucky it's just gonna
look
normal yeah let's go to this octane
light
that we have hidden let's turn that on
and we can set it to more of a blue
color so we can go 8 000
on that or maybe even 10
000
and we'll set the power to like
50.
hmm so it's still looking all cg to me
it's not looking as good as it as it
needs to be
[Music]
it looks better because we're getting
the detail on the wall here
it certainly looks nice um
let's adjust our
depth of field so not everything isn't
super crisp
so in octane camera imager i'm going to
thin lens and the aperture we can just
crank
until we get
something here
let me just set the f-stop to 2.8
2.4 and we'll throw our figure down
right in the middle and we want our
focus to be on that figure right there
i always like to set my aperture aspect
ratio to 2 and the aperture edge to 3
that's going to give you that bokeh
kind of effect
and i might be able to tone down the
emissive
light power so we can maybe take that to
like
50 or something
these floor lights are really
brightening up our scene
and you can see them here up on the roof
it's not too bad um but our
maybe maybe let's go like it's a lot of
tweaking from here all right
we're gonna be tweaking all day long
let's take our power
for the specular down to like point two
maybe it just needs to be crunched
yeah something like that
maybe we could take the normal map and
we'll throw a
multiply on there and we'll connect a
float
to that so we can control the intensity
of the normal map so we can set that to
2 and see what it does for us
in terms of detail
we might want to actually take
the color channel and make it a little
bit larger so the transform let's take
it to two and see what that does like we
might get a bit more detail in this
and i think we can probably throw
a let's see let's throw
a gradient on the color channel
and try and bring out a bit more of
the detail and texture
uh why is that there we go okay
oh that that's crazy looking
you see all that detail in there like
that's that's what we want
we want to really bring out
that grungy detail and then maybe we
take the transform
to 3 or 2.5
and we want the saturation to go
up as well so maybe we take it
what if we take it to 20 what if we okay
three
it won't go past three uh sam hey what's
up dude
thanks for the super chat man very very
generous of you thank you
he says hey you've been a fan since i
was nine years old holy crap that is
insane and you are now in college in a
full-time
freelance filmmaker and it's because of
holy crap
dude that is awesome uh he says thanks
for
the uh thank you so much for the endless
inspiration dude i got you man that is
amazing
so cool to hear um wow
that's legit congratulations you made it
you're doing
uh vfx freelance or not even vfx it's
it's a freelance
filmmaker that is amazing keep it up
keep up the hard work
sam i appreciate you man thanks for
sticking around
for all this time i know there was a
long period where i was putting out i
was not putting out videos
but you stuck through and a lot of you
guys did as well so thank you thank you
thank you so much
for hanging out this image is coming
along we're getting close we need to add
some
a couple more details in here um
but uh we're gonna we're gonna wrap it
out and it's gonna look really cool
so
let's keep going shall we
let's set the aspect ratio
um yeah we can do
1920 by 810
and that is like true widescreen
aspect ratio 237 that's gonna look
really nice when you do something like
this
we'll take it to 0.5 so we can see the
full image like
absolutely beautiful and we can actually
continue
let's do a couple things with the
geometry before we get into this micro
detail up in here
um so
let's go to our cylinder
and let's grab these edges i'm going to
hit ul and we're going to do a loop
selection around this entire thing all
right
and let's fix this symmetry business
going on here um because
there's technically a gap in here
and i do not want that i want to bring
all that stuff together so what i'll do
is let's go to like a front view or
something
and we'll go to point mode let's grab
all those points down the middle
and there should be two points
yep see right here we have this
connection it's not making it
so our points let's see
we should have if i hit alt
v i want to find a i want to find some
information so let's go
to hud total points let's go to
selected points
let's check selected points alright so
now we can see we have
two points selected the front and the
back it should be four points selected
yep
and you can see it up in here top left
and what i want to do
is select all of them down the middle
it's 131 points i should see that
divided by two
i don't know where the extra one is
coming from
but i'm just going to do a little check
all right
and i'm going to hit uo that's optimize
and nothing happened all right so we
know we didn't fix the problem
so now what we need to do let's try
right clicking and do um
can we just weld all of these together
where are you weld all right
um
maybe if i take all of those
and i select them down the middle and we
scale them together
if does this have to be a zero did these
come together
they came together all right so they're
touching now
and now if i hit uo there we go
it fixed it so we basically
brought all the points together we
touched them together and then we hit
uo which is optimize so if we find
optimize right there it optimized
the model whatever that means and it
fixed our issue and we confirmed it
because
we hit alt v and we went to hud
and we made sure that our total points
our total selected points was checked
and we saw that go from 131 to 84. so
now we're good and
in theory if we were to come out here
and we were to go to edge selection we
hit
ul it should just grab
the edge now it's exactly what it did
alright so
perfect absolutely perfect let's go
ahead
and hit t for scale or no we'll hit
the move tool w hold ctrl and we'll
scale that out
just like that i'm gonna hit t and scale
it way
out like that all right and when we hop
into the camera now it's gonna be
just an infinite basically an infinite
expanse
of that texture and it's going to roll
off nicely
now the back i want to fix the back
because the back
it just cuts off but here you actually
see the back
kind of just disappears out into the
abyss which
i really like and i want to capture that
feeling
so what we need to do before we start
matching colors and stuff
is um push that back so i'm hop out of
the camera real quick
and i think i can cut it off
if we come into like a side view here
let's go ahead and grab let's go to
point mode rectangular selection
and let's select everything just beyond
where it starts to
widen out so just like that
and actually what i'll do i'll do it the
other way i'll just grab
those bits delete those and i'm going to
use this
and push this out oh sorry but i'm going
to hold ctrl
so it converts our point selection to an
edge selection
holding control i'll push this just
infinitely back
and now if we hop into
the camera push that back a little bit a
little bit more
that does not look right at all
so maybe what we need to do is first
ensure that it has the right
the right texture on this thing
so i'm going to drop this enamel
material that we have on our walls i'm
going to do u
y wait hold on u l
should be our loop selection but it's
not doing it for some reason
let me just grab everything here it's
because our normals are inverted
so we want to
ctrl shift z undoes camera moves we want
to
align the normal so we'll hit right
click and we want to
align normals that made it worse
that made it worse i'm just clicking it
more and more
um let's select that guy
so it looks like it's from here
over plus this one and then we can hit u
r that's the shortcut for reverse
normals
and it looks to me like that is correct
[Music]
and what i want to do is
double click this selection
which is the selection for our wall
material
and i am going to just do a blanket uh
selection of all of this stuff back here
so i'm gonna hold shift
and grab all of that and i should be
able to with this
selection tag selected update it by uh
the selection i have a pre-made button
or you can go to select
set selection and now you can see the
material was applied
back into perspective mode or
perspective view
we can see here that that tunnel just
goes back into infinity
and to give it a bit more that
spotlighty effect i think what i'm going
to do
is take these cloners
okay and i'm going
to cut them off from the back there
so let me just grab both the cloners
and scoot them back this way so it's
just
lighting more so the foreground than it
is the background and you're getting
that effect where it kind of falls off
into the darkness
i like that a lot um
sweet
yep i don't understand uvs entirely but
that's all good
we're making making progress
all right
so the color i'm getting here is very
washed out and i think that has to do
with my
texture for some reason it made it black
and white when i threw a gradient on
here
um that's because probably this is set
to black so
if i want the original color from this
maybe what i need to do is just get rid
of that for a second
and set my saturation back to one and
probably just adjust
my saturation i'm sorry
my contrast here
you
awesome
i also like how these lights are a bit
blue
versus straight white
so i wonder let's see if i take
if i go to my camera settings
camera imager saturate to oh it's
saturated white is already at zero the
white point though
if we set it to orange a little orange
it'll go a little blue
you can see if i crank it it'll kind of
blew out but
that that's that's kind of gross set
that back to
back to default and we can mess with
different um
[Music]
different responses here
so some of these can start to look
pretty sweet
and some of them are a bit more
contrasty than others
and i'm just experimenting going up and
down the list
seeing what looks nicest
that's not bad um
now the subdivision surface um
like it i want it to kind of smooth out
this outer
rung here and it's not doing it in the
render but it is doing it in the
viewport
i'm wondering if the renderer can be set
to like
three but that's not really doing much
um it might just be the way
bless you it might just be the way i
have uh
that's this one here
so we're getting close we just need to
get that detail up in here and maybe put
something in the middle
um but how are you guys doing in the
chat we're almost done here we're just
going to add that last little bit of
detail
um render it out while i announce the
winners of the weekly challenge and then
maybe do a little tweaking in photoshop
right after
i announce this week's challenge but go
ahead and give me a thumbs up
right if you guys are doing okay go
ahead and like the video
and leave a comment for something that
you'd like for me to live stream next
that's actually something that's been
difficult is to figure out hey what's
the next live stream
going to be so please leave a comment uh
down below
it helps me out a lot because there's
you know
i'm a busy man i got a lot of things
going on and if you guys can help me out
with what you want to see next
on the next live stream i do them every
week it helps out a whole bunch
okay so subdivision isn't working
because the bevel is breaking it
need to put bevel and cylinder into a
null
let's try it let's put both of those
guys into a null and see what happens
whoa
whoa that's crazy
so what i want to do let's see
it seems you're right it seems you are
correct
let me think about this
so the bevel
it's certainly um it certainly adds a
lot of detail to the edges
you know if we zoom in here i'll just
set this to like two or something
you can see how the light catches the
edges of everything
um without the bevel
so i'll do a render region for you guys
here
and we will compare we'll store the
render buffer
and then i'll do one without the bevel
or so that's without i'll do it with
did that even work oh yeah it's because
so it's a very subtle difference here on
the wall
um and it's giving me this white line
that i'm not quite sure how to deal with
you might be able to catch it more on
this window
so that's with the bevel we'll store it
and then we'll turn it off and you'll
see the difference
so i'm wondering in this case because we
have all the time in the world
i'm wondering if i break
the cardinal rule and i don't bevel
because let's be honest this is going to
be viewed on instagram
and instead i do the subdivision surface
oh but it looks like ah looks horrible
it looks horrible because now the
subdivision surface it needs more
geometry up in these windows
and it's specifically the windows it
makes everything else look nice
but the bevel
so maybe what i'll oh shoot maybe what
i'll do
let me think about this
hmm maybe i have to go in and manually
do these windows
all right the connect effector maybe use
the connect effector
um instead of a null
i don't know if that would work
connect sometimes messes with the
yeah not good
all right let's try and
figure out this problem
i wonder if this is a hierarchy thing or
what um
let's get out of the camera
subdivision surface is chunking up my
windows
so what i need to do i need to apply
this bevel modifier
wait what what is going on
and q to get rid of textures and c to
get rid of lights
so we can see a little bit better here
maybe what i have to do is just select
all this stuff
manually
so i'm selecting all my edges manually
and then we'll do a bevel modifier
on just the parts that need to be
beveled versus the entire
thing
so this is a tedious process here
very meticulous we want to make sure
this is
right okay so i'm gonna do it on one
side first to make sure it works and
then i'll do on the other side before i
waste time
um i'm wondering if this is what's
stopping
us from selecting the loop
across the top
that's still hard to get that loop
across the top um i wonder if it's
happening on the bottom too
no yes
ah yeah i don't think that's gonna
happen there
um
let's try this let's set this selection
and we'll turn the bevel modifier on
ah it needs more than that shoot this is
tough guys
maybe what i have to do instead of
subdividing everything
i'm gonna have to do it another way
instead i think what i'm gonna have to
do
is just bevel um the actual
oh shoot that's not gonna work either i
could smooth it maybe
i think i'm like too far gone at this
point
like this is the tough tough part
because
i should have done this before
i have a crazy idea
this is so dumb okay i save out two
images
one image is this one with the bevel or
with the subdivision surface and the
other image is
with the bevel on the lights
that's probably what i'm gonna do that's
the fastest way to get rid of that
um but let's go ahead and finish up this
image
and do our roof detail all right so
long ago i downloaded something from
bridge earlier on in the stream
um favorites let's see where would it be
purchased
oh what the heck
3d assets i swear i downloaded it
here we go the rusty square drain
i'll export this boom into our scene and
we'll put this up on the roof
and it's going to look real nice real
nice
successfully exported cool and also
another thing that i want to do
to get sidetracked even further i'm
going to zoom in here
and i want to select all of these deep
grooves here
so ul is for loop selection
and i want to get inside these grooves
here
and for some reason it's making it
difficult on me
let's select all these edges or all
these faces we'll go
uy we're going to grow that selection
okay and we're going to do it again and
again and then we'll deselect
everything here and that ensures
that we actually have the uh this groove
selected right
and we'll get these corners
and i want to fill in these grooves with
that dark metal texture that way
we really have uh those deep crevices
and i can probably
do the same thing with like an ambient
occlusion pass
and i might just do that as well but
just to show you guys you can do it this
way as well
and i want to select
this groove here probably let's go ahead
and set our selection
before we get too far i'm gonna hit ul
we'll get that guy and we'll get this
guy holding shift
hit u y once and that's going to get
those selections there
and actually i'll undo that i'm going to
come back here
and get these faces first and then i'll
grow the selection
cool i hit ui and
we'll hit uh let's see
oh it's not getting these weird
that's because those dang stoppers
and we'll throw the gunmetal onto those
little crevices
what happened up here do we lose our
selection
we may have so i'll select
this again uy three times
and then make sure we have our corners
see i still have so much to improve when
it comes to efficiency
on my workflow
i'm spending a lot of time redoing stuff
um tweaking is fine you have to tweak
all day
but i'm kind of going back and forth
here on the workflow
but that's okay that's how you learn
trial and error see now you got that
deep dark
groove
and it looks a little bit closer to the
reference
let's go ahead and bring in our
our rusty square drain which looks like
it brought it in
so that rusty square drain
we will will apply to
these bits here okay so i'm just gonna
grab that drop our drain texture on
and it's huge so let's go into that
drain texture
take the transform and just set it to
like point two
um and it looks like we need to focus
our camera
and figure out what the heck is
happening here
so maybe this is a case where we set our
projection to
box again and we work it in that way
make sure you guys save your work save
your work
there we go so now it's uh
it's actually centered up and looking
good
and when you scale it down it's actually
scaling down
pretty properly here um
looks like it needs to be adjusted a
little bit so let's go ahead and
mess with our transform settings
something like that and
like that okay
and then i'm just going to apply that
metal texture
to this rim here as well
and probably take the color channel here
on our grating
and drop the saturation
to like point three
cool something like that
very nice
and maybe i'll come in here
and scale this up so i'm gonna hit u y a
couple more times
yep hit t and i'm just gonna scale up
that little selection
there
and i'll have to actually scale up the
uh
the texture itself to fit within that
those bounds 0.85 that's good
and maybe we give the camera a bit of uh
post process glow
bloom power let's go 150
let's hop in and check the camera
because it's not going to work unless we
uh
hop into our camera here let's see
it's not working for some reason i don't
i don't know why
that's weird
oh wait
is it because
oh no that should be it
problem solving all day long it's cool i
can do without it
um i want to get these last little bits
up here so maybe i'll
throw in like uh
that same metal texture
so i'll hop out
sweet
so now it just needs a subject
so we could go with that airplane
um
yeah why not i'm just gonna make a new
project file very quickly here
or you know what i wonder if we can just
go to like turbosquid
and download a a free airplane
model because that'd be a lot faster
and probably a lot more accurate
all right so let's see what we can find
let's search
price free
this is all great um
yeah i feel like uh i feel like this
first one will probably do us
right here obj that's all we'll need so
i'm going to
briefly download this
all right like 30 seconds here guys
if you have any questions for me go
ahead and ask i'll uh answer some
while this model is downloading and
transferring in
you
all right um
all right yoni do i have any experience
in unreal engine 4 i do a little bit
yeah i'm learning it
it's very difficult it's very
complicated but i do think it's the
future
and i'm definitely putting some time in
to learn
that program i'm going to delete
everything except for the phong tag
so our smoothness is okay and i'm just
going to go ahead i'll probably
delete the landing gear
or just hide it and i'll bring
this model
right into our project file
and scale it way up
so you guys are asking about next week's
live stream next week i'm actually going
to be
in yosemite so i will not be live
streaming next week but
i am going to be uploading a uh a quick
tip tutorial for you guys on how to get
the most realistic motion blur outside
of after effects by default motion blur
in after effects is very soft
and very um it doesn't preserve your
highlights like a real camera would
so i'll show you the difference between
um
default motion blur and how bad it
actually is
compared to this trick that i want to
show you guys that i actually learned
from andrew kramer when he came into the
corridor office
and he showed us this trick that blew my
mind it blew all of our minds
and i'd like to share that with you guys
as well and maybe give you a little bit
of backstory on uh
on a picture that you may or may not
have seen
but uh yeah that'll be next week while
i'm gone so it'll just be a
like probably an eight minute long quick
tip produced kind of video
um so let's go ahead and render our
scene here
let's give it a minute and i'm just
going to throw
a chrome texture
down that's an octane glossy material
index will set to 1 and that makes it
pure gloss
so i'll drop that on the airplane and
that looks really really cool
yeah that's awesome
so to get the actual silhouette of the
airplane we probably need to
drop our camera just a little bit lower
and it looks like our post process
is actually working we just need to set
the bloom power like
oh it's the that's why it's because the
cut off
there we go
obviously really intense um the glare
blur will set to 1
and we'll take the cut off way down
probably just something like that that's
cool
um
then let's go ahead and give
the airplane
like a stand or something so it's
actually on
a platform
so i'm going to hop out of camera view
and i'm just going to do some very basic
cylinders
i'm not even going to worry too much
about it i'll scale that down
make it editable um scale it up
like this
and then i'm just going to make the
bottom like base piece
or maybe even this top piece here
i'll just scale that down oh geez
i did that wrong okay i need to get rid
of height segments
set that to zero first then we make it
editable
scale it up
and then we scale that down
something like that
and we'll just put one in the front
one in the back and call it a day
put the gloss texture on there or the
chrome texture down
sweet
that's awesome
sweet okay so the only thing i'm not
really happy with are
these lights i feel like they're lacking
a bit of texture
maybe what i can do um
i'm just gonna try something crazy i'm
gonna throw some fog down
an octane fog volume
um let's go ahead and pause the renderer
and before i go any further and crash my
system
let's take the voxel size to 50
and then we'll hide it in the viewport
let's go ahead and render and it's so
thick we can't see through it but let's
go to medium
we'll set the density to 0.1
0.01
and it's probably this is probably not
needed i think it's just gonna
it's not really going to do what we need
it to do um
0.001
yeah it's not necessary it's really not
necessary i thought maybe it could do a
little something for us but
no worries um
what else
what else
maybe we take this viewing window here
and
go to visibility will turn off camera
visible
i guess that didn't really do much we
can push it back just a little bit
and maybe is it worth
throwing down just a little bit of
of detail in here
so we can do a cube or something
and i'm just immediately
going to make it editable and i'll
delete this face
delete this face
and see if we can't just like
kind of give this room a little bit of
shape
let's go ahead and select with ul loop
selection
bring this in just a little bit
just to kind of fill out this room maybe
um
and we'll push this back in our light
where's our light maybe we push the
light back a little bit
oh what
that's not good what maybe it's time to
uh to upgrade
so that gives it just a little bit of
something
um maybe we tint the window or something
a little bit too
we can go to that glass
let's go to fake shadows we'll check
that on
reflection
what would i do to tint the glass is it
transmission
yeah maybe something like that
it gives us just like a little bit of
something
um and then maybe i take that room
then i push it back just a little bit
more
and we can take that light and actually
bump it up a little bit so we're getting
some sort of gradient in that room
it's helping a little bit
there we go
sweet so i think what we can do now um
we i feel like we lost our reflections
just a hair
if we take our ceiling lights this
emissive
let me take it to 100
or 500 we go overboard
i definitely want to keep oh that's what
happened so this gradient
here this is what we didn't this is what
we didn't do
um let's see specular
we can crank that higher
there we go and that'll give us a bit
more uh
detail in our gradient i'm going to turn
on the subdivision surface for a second
just to see how that works
give it a moment
re-render maybe
whoa what is happening
lots of errors
do
okay
so
all right so i'm wondering if i can uh
if i can fix that issue by
beveling these grooves
by hand
so i can set that selection and i'll
drop a bevel modifier
into the cylinder
and i'll make sure that bevel modifier
has
this edge selection piped in
and we'll set that to i don't know set
that to
three subdivisions point one
on the bevel and that looks like it's
doing a better job i just hate how it
like
excludes the texture because it's making
new geometry but because we're actually
using a
selection on the
material it's not including it on this
new geometry that was created because of
the bevel modifier which is
super lame
but does that fix oh man
it doesn't fix the subdivision surface
issue
unless i just straight up apply this
material to the entire thing
what on earth
that is so ugly
yeah definitely having trouble with that
but that's not that's not half bad
that's not half bad
all right so i'm going to let's let's
experiment here with a different aspect
ratio so i'm going to go
900 by 600 that's 2 3
aspect ratio
which i believe is what my camera shoots
in
you
i'm just trying to find my angle now
basically most of the work is done
you
that's pretty cool it's not bad
all right i think that's it guys
i think that's it
so i'm gonna i'm gonna render this out
and we'll do a little bit of
in photoshop and while um
while this renders i'm going to announce
the winners of this week's weekly
challenge the prompt was aquatic
and every time we do these we get more
and more submissions which is super
cool and very promising because
in the next month or so there's
something
very very very special that is going to
happen um
myself and nvidia
uh also with p and y we're gonna we're
doing something cool we're working on
something
really really cool for you guys so keep
up these challenges all right it's going
to pay off i promise
um we got something really awesome
planned for you
uh in the next month or so next month or
two
we'll see we're still working out the
details so i can't see any specifics yet
but get amped because
myself nvidia and p and y are teaming up
to do something awesome with you guys
all right
so keep up these challenges let me set
up my render settings here i'm going to
go 1920 by 1080 just so
we can you know get something out
um i want the current frame
i'll save a
an open exr 16 bit that's totally fine
we don't need alpha channel
let me save it to the right spot here
before i forget
yep the beard is gone the beard is gone
indeed
all right let's uh let's save this to
the right spot
sweet um let's go ahead and give it
a render pass let's
go ambient occlusion
sweet um let's make sure we
save the render pass ambient occlusion
maybe we can
tighten up that ambient occlusion just a
bit the distance
there we go something like that we can
get our grooves nice and
nice and tight
awesome okay save that out
and let's find a place for that
2 000 samples
let's up the depth of everything 32
32 and 16.
and let's go ahead and render
very nice awesome all right so that's
going
um yeah let's talk about these winners
okay so
again the challenge was aquatic all
right
and you guys delivered a lot of cool
stuff
we're getting more and more submissions
so let's pull up these winners here
um and i'll give them a critique we'll
go over the winners and see what they
did well what they can do better
um and i'm just realizing here looking
at
my my texture i think i need to
scale it down so i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop this render give me give me one
second
let's cancel that let's go back
to this enamel and
we'll take the transform down to
1.25 and then we'll render
and we'll see how that's that looks a
little bit nicer
okay so um
without further ado let's talk about
these challenge
winners so let's pull them up here
bear with me while i pull up the right
all right file here we go okay all right
so
the first winner of this week's weekly
challenge which you guys can join by
following
the link down below goes to the discord
server uh we do one every single week
this one was aquatic and the first
winner is
edward look at this
this is from uh what is it life aquatic
i think that's the name of the movie
it's got
bill murray in it um i love this render
that you put out man very cool
uh it was a very different style than
what everyone else
did and i really like that this so this
certainly stood out your lighting was
really nice your color is really nice
your composition and framing really
really nice okay
so a couple um
critiques for you i think the scratches
here
on the submarine are a little heavy
i think you can you can chill out on
those also you see how this scratch
is coming up and out of the submarine
you gotta reverse your normals
so the scratches are going into the
submarine and it looks like
parts are are going into the submarine
parts or not
so just make sure your normals are
correct with all this
um because you don't want scratches
bulging out of your submarine you can
see it here
it looks like that's happening it may
not be
but it looks like it you did a really
good job here with the atmosphere
there's a lot of a lot of fog and
atmosphere coming in through here which
is really nice
um yeah the scratches on the glass
they're they're a little speckled they
can be
uh they're a little heavy i think you
can come down on those a bit
that'd be the main thing i think you can
also add
it looks like you added a little bit of
blur to your image which is good
you don't want it to be like that pixel
perfect pixel sharp images i love your
bubbles
overall this is just a really solid
image edward so congratulations man you
are a winner of this week's
weekly challenge your image will be in
the challenge
winners channel for all to see and you
will get
the role of challenge winner this week
on the create with clint discord server
alright so next up
coming in there's no placement there's
no first second place it's just the top
five baby
next up we have ice cream paint job
constantly putting out good work
dude you are one of the next
level artists on the discord superman
your work is so good look at this detail
there's like i love how you add subtle
motion blur
and subtle um just camera blur to all of
your renders
you have such a good eye for detail and
there's also
film grain in here too which is really
nice
i think this was something i mentioned
earlier
um it looks like you have
that subtle motion blur over
your your grain and i think you need to
the green is the final layer so your
grain shouldn't be blurry
or motion blurred at all and it looks
like there's subtle motion blur
happening
on your grain so make sure that's not
the case
next time um yeah the model is great i
think
you probably downloaded the models uh
you posed them correctly
and you made sure the textures are
looking really nice you lit it really
well
all right um a couple critiques one
framing
all right i think you can crop out the
the bottom here
if you're going to stick with this
aspect ratio i would zoom in a bit more
i would focus more on the subject
this is a very cinematic kind of setup
so personally i would go
widescreen 235 super cinematic aspect
ratio crop the bottom out
make it look nice
another critique personally i would give
it a bit
more
contrast when it comes to the light
let me let me be clear because that
might sound a little confusing
personally i would add some ships in the
background some lights from
some foggy lights in the background like
maybe a city
is way back there and the lights are on
and there's just the subtle
warm glow back here along the horizon um
or maybe there's some like
like some towers with some lights in the
background it'd be really nice to see a
bit of uh
of light detail in the background here
it would just give it a bit of color
contrast i think it could look really
nice also another thing
i know this dude is all like black ops
to the max right now but it'd be nice to
get a little bit of subtle glow maybe on
his like night vision or something
any sort of little tiny light details
you can add to this i think would make
it a little bit better
but it's already great so again ice
cream paint job congratulations you are
a winner of this week's weekly challenge
you're getting that role of challenge
winner this week
it might get stolen from you next week
but this week it's yours all right
so moving on to our third winner we got
lucky strike three with this awesome
image here it is a
ship caught at sea in a storm dude
the biggest thing i love about this is
your lighting you really nailed the
lighting here
there was actually a very similar render
when we did storm uh
one or two weeks ago
[Music]
but i actually really like what you did
here you have that fog layer in the back
which looks like a z-depth pass in
photoshop that you kind of used as a fog
layer
that's really nice that's a good way to
use it your rain is nice it's got some
uh
you know you got your motion blur on the
rain there
um your waves could use some work you
could use some
foam in your waves all right and i know
waves and water is very difficult in 3d
there's plugins for it like hot 4d is a
cinema 4d plugin for waves
i think it stands for houdini ocean
[Music]
houdini ocean something but hot 4d
is definitely something to look into it
does the foam really well and it
uses it uses a displacement map to
really get the waves right
definitely here you got some spikeys i
think you could probably subdivide your
plane
which you're using for your water a
little bit better but your ship is great
i i assume you downloaded this model
from turbo squid looks really good
your lights are nice it's just a very
cinematic shot you have here i like it a
lot
maybe you can go a little darker you can
add a bit more contrast to the image
but i like how you maintain detail in
the darks right
you didn't crush the blacks too much um
but yeah i dig your composition and i
dig your lighting your
your clouds back here really nice it
rolls off really well
and you have some atmosphere going too
which is great
um the ripples in your water yeah we
talked about the water could be a little
bit larger
a bit more detailed you need the foam
for sure
um but yeah
overall um lucky strike three you're
you're a challenge winner this week so
congratulations you're getting the role
of challenge winner
and your image will be in the challenge
winners
uh channel for all to see so
congratulations
you're hanging on to that role for this
week
next up second to last but not in fourth
place
we have mdk a similar render i use the
boat but i do i love this so much
because i
zoomed in and found some really funny
stuff
let's take a look first off we note it's
in a pool all right
um we can see the drain here you can see
the tiles down below
these are they're toys plastic army men
this is really nice
your detail is really nice your textures
are really nice
look big evil corporation here on the
side
they're dumping bottles of pee into the
pool
and just how heinous
is heinous is the word that comes to
mind
um that's hilarious you have a story you
got your police
boats coming up your plastic police
boats coming up stopping the evil
corporation guys big evil corp
from them and pee in the pool don't do
it it's not chill they have to drain the
whole pool it's expensive guys
great work on this man so good um i love
your lighting
i love your scene i love your story and
look at this even this guy got shot
blood pools
blood pools up here look at this the
model is so good
i don't know if you modeled this
yourself if you did congratulations
really great work the only thing i would
add is some subtle surface imperfections
maybe on the wheels maybe the edges were
scratched a bit
maybe there's some dust in the corners
that's what i'd probably added some dust
in the corners
um but overall man this is so good
i love it my first impression though was
that
uh the tiling here on the bottom of the
pool
is actually on the surface it's like a
uh a wire frame look on the surface of
the water
it's what i thought at first i don't
know quite what you could do to fix that
i don't know
maybe it's because the bottom of pools
are not always tile it's like a
granite kind of a
concrete look i don't know that's such a
nitpick though
otherwise mdk you're a challenge winner
this week you're getting the role of
challenge winner and your
image will be presented and held up for
the week
in the challenge winners channel and
last but not least
for this week winning the challenge
of aquatic we have raven loop with this
absolutely incredible render like what
the heck man let's zoom in
look at the detail on this your lighting
is incredible
the atmosphere you have going is so good
like i i don't really have any notes on
this
other than these pixels down here what
the heck
what the heck
what'd you do
that's some like texture polygon
displacement issues going
on here shame shame on you because look
at this incredible image
you got your subsurface scattering here
and these tentacles dude this thing is
disgusting
your lighting is so nice i'm just i'm
i'm playing man
yeah this is an issue but it doesn't
detract
fantastic work look at the detail you
got the spray paint can down here
the wd-40 whatever it is look at these
images
it's actually part of a video you can
actually find
the video in the chat the the challenge
winners
channel on the discord after the stream
because
ah it's absolutely it's absolutely
beautiful
congratulations to you
raven loop for winning the challenge
this week and all the other winners
for winning the aquatic challenge i've
been talking for so long my throat hurts
my throat hurts after every stream
let me get some water for just a second
guys
and check the render how's the render
looking it's probably finished
if i had to guess it's finished
not bad i think that room could
definitely use a bit more detail but hey
at the end of the day this is being
viewed on instagram
okay
so let's um
let's hop into photoshop and tweak this
image
do a little color correction take it to
the next level
you know what i mean boom there's my
thumbnail
i've been working on my thumbnails but
let's go ahead and drop this in file
open
um boom
all right and okay so before i get going
on this
i want to hear you guys thoughts what do
you guys want to do for this next
challenge this week what are you guys
feeling
go ahead and leave your uh
your submissions here in the live chat
i'm watching right now
what do you guys want to do for the
challenge this week we can base it off
of
the image i'm doing here and try and
figure something out together
um and just tom there's a plane because
this is a
uh what do you call it
a wind tunnel and they're testing the
aerodynamics of the of an airplane
blade runner challenge pokemon challenge
dune challenge snow we did snow
coffee challenge interesting city rainy
day
challenge oh time dude that's some
abstract ancient
western
hmm desert space sunlight all right i'm
watching you guys so the main thing
that i find with the challenge
submissions
is your guys is lighting your scenes are
always nice
your clay renders look nice and then i
see your lighting
and it detracts from the overall
feeling of the image um
so really try and work on your lighting
this week when you're doing the
challenge okay
really try and spend that time to make
it look really nice
all right i'm still looking scattered
moon stuff sci-fi horror organic
steampunk could be cool
darkness just submit a black frame
yeah time might be a really crazy one
so i'm holding on to time i got time all
right
but i think we can we can all work on
our lighting
so what could be a lighting challenge
[Music]
hmm
maybe
maybe not this week but uh next week or
the week after we can do a lighting
challenge where i supply you guys with
one 3d file
and you have to light it the best you
can
that could be interesting
all right still looking macro we did
macro
war inception
negative space i like that um
lamps film noir
interior scene for lighting
all right maybe what we do
is all right churaskiro
chiraskiro that's a lighting style um
cheeriskiro
chia cheer oscaro um it's an old
lighting technique used in
paintings back in the day it was
developed
i mean i don't really know the details
of it
and how it was developed but
this might be a little too
[Music]
hmm is this too much
i guess this is kind of abstract it's
hard to base off of uh
if you just google this you guys can see
all this cheriskiro lighting it's very
um silhouette it's like looks like it's
coming from one source
a lot use of lots of negative space i
love this style of
lighting lighting you know a lot of
movies were lit like this i know
children of men had a lot of scenes like
this
um barry lyndon had a lot of scenes like
this
all right i'm still looking here i'm
still looking at your guys contrast
sculpting
um car renders apocalypse
all right
i usually like to put it between two
things so we have time as one thing
and um what could be the second
um okay basic still life for composition
and lighting
now the still life i i feel like the
best way to do that challenge is for me
to provide you guys
with a model like this right provide you
with
this model in this scene and then you
have to light it as best as possible
i think that could be a really a really
fun challenge because
then it just is fixed fixated on the
lighting you know and i get to see how
you guys
light all your different stuff
all right
maybe between apocalypse and time
what do you guys think okay here i'll do
three all right between these three
apocalypse time and noir
all right what do you think
apocalypse time or noir
the voting begins
no it is certainly not important that
the software you use
it's never important the software you
use it's how you use it
all right lots of time
noir it's kind of a split between time
and noir
no spamming i'm trusting you guys
noir
time oh man this is like a tough split
jeez
oh my god it's like right down the
middle
shoot okay um we can always do noir next
week let's try time
time it is we're doing time time is the
challenge
for this week's weekly challenge you
have to render something using the
prompt
time all right you can go all out on
this
it can be as as specific as possible as
crazy as possible whatever you want
whatever whatever
scene that comes to mind when you think
of time i don't care
what you do but you have to submit one
photo
one render okay it could be a render it
could be a drawing could be a painting
the whole point is we want to get better
at the craft that we are passionate
about
so um yeah i think all bets are off
on this one just don't copy anyone's
work don't follow a tutorial and just
post a tutorial you're gonna have to
actually use your brain juice on this
one and come up with something
um something really interesting
something really cool i think
this is a fun prompt it's very vague
which is cool because a lot of different
renders come
from these vague prompts all right so
um join the discord server the link is
in the description
below i'm going to post the rules the
specific rules
to this challenge if you guys have any
questions
and it's where you're going to want to
submit as well so definitely join the
discord server
if you're not subscribe to these videos
subscribe to the channel
alright so you guys can come back every
week and get better with me so we can
all get better at what we're trying to
do
and leave a comment of the next uh live
stream that you want to see what do you
want to learn next all right
i'm not doing blender all right that's
the only thing i'm not doing blender
because i don't use blender that's it
but i'm open to anything else so i
really like this i think this turned out
really well
um i think i'm going to
[Music]
render one more here
and just pull my depth of field down a
bit it's a
it's a little crazy alright so the way
i'm gonna
test my depth of field
let's go ahead and render this
give it a moment
yeah don't spam guys darren deerin will
boot ya
if he has to all right so let's let's
keep it chill
let's see how crispy
oh that actually looks pretty sweet
for some reason having a
just a ball in the middle of this thing
looks really cool
why why is that the case
a chrome ball perhaps
that's a lot of bloom isn't it
yeah that's crazy just kidding um let's
let's bring this back
i'm just using this to test my depth of
field
let's go ahead and i just want to render
this bit because it looks
soft to me
so right in here it's looking
soft and i'm wondering it's got to be
the depth of field right
so let's take that up and then let's
actually let's adjust
the normal i'm going to set it to 2
and that feels a bit better to me if i
set it to three
now we'll go one we'll keep it at one
yeah that's totally fine i'm going to
re-render
with that corrected i think it's a lot
better that way
so let me just do
a v2 right here or render two
let's render that out and while that's
going let's just work on the color
correction in photoshop the first thing
i always do
the first thing i always do is throw a
film green over the top
so i'm going to go ahead and open
uh vfx materials overlays t-max 100.
it's really nice with black and white
film stock
so i'll drop that in
all right hold on give me a second i
need to take down
before i do that i'll go back to 8 bits
we'll hit ok right there and now we'll
bring in our tmax
and we'll set it to overlay and you get
a nice
film grain effect it's very subtle
it's almost too subtle
yikes come on but we are getting a nice
film green effect over the top of this
um
[Music]
let's mess with ctrl shift a to bring up
adobe camera raw
and actually no i'm not going to do that
because i want to just replace the image
and have it have all my changes work all
right so let's go ahead and throw down
some some curves
and what we might do is lift the blacks
so they're not entirely black kind of
gives you that filmic look
the blacks are lifted just a hair
and those highlights are brought up
a bit and we can bring the white point
down
just a little bit
that's so subtle like we really don't
need much
here um i really like how it turned out
we can maybe adjust the human saturation
something like that maybe that's so
subtle
yeah it's so subtle we don't need to do
much here guys
it just looks really cool
let's check the render
and it's done two minutes and 20 seconds
i believe it's finished
all right so what we'll do oh
are you kidding me did it render it with
the sphere it rendered it with the
sphere
i'm pretty sure it rendered it with the
sphere let's try it again let's go for
v3
we'll drop in that v2
yikes okay back up back up back up
let's grab our v2
drop it in okay
oh i don't think it rendered it with the
sphere
but you can see here the highlights
were crisped up just a bit because of
the uh
the depth of field there
which helps us out certainly
now you can see this edge here
that's no good we want that to fall off
to black
so i think what we'll do is
i'm gonna just grab this render i'ma
duplicate it ctrl
j and i want to make it editable so
basically i'm going to
rasterize the layer now
if i select it and i grab the clone
stamp tool
i'm basically just going to grab some of
this like
this dark space here and
let's get it right in the middle there
i'm going to set it to
let's set it to 75 opacity
and just kind of draw a circle around
this
and that's gonna hopefully actually
doesn't
i feel like that's not really doing what
we need it's the difficult way to do
what we need
um
[Music]
what's the best way to do this probably
with a vignette to be honest
so what we could do is just make a new
a new layer
make it black and
we will erase the center point
we'll make sure our hardness is at zero
drop the opacity to 50 so we can
actually see what we're doing
and just get in there like that turn up
the opacity to 100
all right so that's kind of like our
vignette
and then i'm going to go let's do
filter blur let's go gaussian blur and
really blur it out
about like that okay and then we can
just set the opacity
somewhere somewhere in here
and that that takes care of that it
basically will fall off to that
that darkness
but like we said we wanted to lift those
blacks
so i'll drop it down just a little bit
underneath our uh our color correction
layers if you know what i mean
so we'll go back in um yep we got that
v3 which we didn't need because uh i
actually didn't render it with the
sphere
but that looks pretty sweet to me
i'm really digging that a whole lot
let's see if we can't
include our ambient occlusion layer so
let's
drag ambient occlusion in
and it's wonky um
i don't know how to do this in photoshop
to be honest
file image
hmm
maybe if we go to back to the picture
viewer
we go to the layer ambient occlusion it
is here
so i can right click um or i go
file save image as and we can just do
this as like a png
an 8 bit png is totally fine
and we'll call this ao
and now we have it so back into
photoshop
we'll drop that on there boom cool and
then we'll set this to multiply
so you can see when i go off and on with
it
it's filling in those lights it's giving
us detail
yes this is what we need it's giving us
detail
that we don't have like you see in the
airplane
you can also see in these lights i think
it's doing the best work in these lights
up here
so we can even take that that ambient
occlusion
will rasterize it okay and then we'll
throw some levels on it
and obviously that's the most intense
version of it
but something like something like that
i'm digging um
also like we may not need it
in these corners here so what i'm going
to do is just actually select
the area that is just the window
and the lights
there holding shift
and i'm going to hit uh
what is it shift i and that's going to
invert our selection and i'm going to
delete
did i do this right ctrl shift i
ctrl shift i and then we delete so now
the ambient occlusion is just happening
in the windows
okay and actually before i delete
i'm going to duplicate
and i have to make this selection again
because i suck at photoshop
now if you guys follow corridor crew you
know there's a guy who works there named
griffin
and griffin does all of our thumbnails
and he is so good at them
he's been in photoshop for so long the
dude is a champion
he knows photoshop like i know after
effects or cinema 4d
all right control shift i delete okay so
the ambient occlusion is only happening
to the windows now what i'll do actually
is i'm going to do a reverse
so i'll if you hold ctrl and you select
that
ambient occlusion layer it's going to
select everything
in the layer right so i got that
selection back i'm going to pop open
this ambient occlusion and i'm actually
going to
[Music]
i did i guess it did it it okay so
yeah it's how we want it let's set this
to
screen
because basically we want all of the
dark parts
to be brighter we want we want the dark
parts oh so what i'll do is i'll
actually invert this
oh weird yeah it's probably not doing
what we needed to do
i'm just going to say nah on that and
stick with what we have
because what we have is pretty great
right there we're just getting the
lights with that
that is so cool i love that so much
um any other things we want to do i'm
probably gonna
throw down smart sharpen on this to
bring out some of the details
so we'll go filter sharpen smart
sharpen
and we'll set the amount
to like five percent
the radius we can set the point five
percent
and we basically want to get let's see
in here um
[Music]
maybe 100 or something
yeah it's just going to bring out those
details a little bit more so i'll hit
okay
very nice we got our film grain up in
here
that's looking nice we can even
adjust that film green it's pretty gross
um just a little bit that's pretty sweet
to me
um i'm feeling that
i'd almost call this finished um i know
i smart sharpened but i'm
probably going to do
a little bit of blur on it just to get
rid of
that pixelation that that like
render perfect sharp edges so i know
that was weird what i just did
and maybe i should have done it the
other way around in fact
nah let's go uh let's go blur
gaussian blur and we'll set it to zero
point one okay set it to one obviously
that is too much
so we'll go filter blur gaussian blur
we'll set it to
point two
yeah point two is fine
that looks pretty sweet to me
i dig it
all right guys that that's basically it
thanks for joining me on this journey um
we successfully put out an image
um by one of my favorite photographers
joe nishizawa
check him out he's got some cool stuff
but um
thank you for joining everybody
definitely stick around
um and join the discord server we're
talking about a bunch of cool stuff in
there
if you guys have any questions specific
questions we got a lot of people
answering those questions i hop in there
as well of course
i mean it's my server so i'm in there
too um
but uh but yeah thanks for joining guys
you guys are awesome
and i will not be live streaming next
week
but i will have a video to upload for
you on saturday
it's actually some really cool after
effects tips on motion blur and how to
make them look
actually correct because no one does it
correctly
in after effects i have learned um you
need to preserve those highlights
definitely want to preserve those
highlights so stick around
subscribe to the channel if you're not
and don't miss out
that's basically it guys um
i'll probably be seeing you uh in the
discord server
that's all i have to offer today thanks
for sticking around
y'all are the best so uh until next time
peace guys later